giggle est la fondatrice de la
pâtisserie griffon le griffon étant
l'emblème de ses ancêtres écossais elle
fait des sablés depuis son enfance elle
fait dans leurs petites boutiques peggy
et sa fille d'un siphon ces fameux
biscuits que les écossais appelle des
chocs bras pour la grand-mère de peggy
c'était une gâterie réservé à la période
des fêtes
pour elle c'est une chose qu'on fait
souvent parler noël pour les fêtes
et elle le fait à juste après
l'halloween
l effet est elle le cache les chalets
cache jusqu'à la première des dix ans
parce que c'est servi pour les fêtes
souvent mais c'est grâce à une autre
famille écossaise que l'on connaît ici
les sables et c'est en 1898 que joseph
roy que 21 ans ouvre les portes de sa
boulangerie dans le village d'arbres en
écosse pour préparer ce qu'il espère
être le meilleur sable et du mans en
1936 avec deux de ses fils joseph
acquiert son premier fourgon de
livraison les produits wacker se
retrouve alors partout en grande
bretagne et sont aujourd'hui exporté à
travers le monde
vous allez nous montrer à faire les
sables et le sable et où comme on dit ça
peggy mélange d'abord le beurre et le
sucre
bon je vais ajouter la farine
tout d'un coup le buzz c'est un tiers de
la recette la farine était fait plus que
le beurre et le succès est à moitié de
la faire de la farine quand on fait le
les abeilles on le mange pour que le
beurre on veut la farine pas que le
ferry ou absorbent le beurre c'est ça
les départs ont alors comme ça c'est de
lui se dit bien ensemble comme ça je
vais le finir à la main
[Musique]
c'est notre médaille en comme ça mais ça
se fait dans toutes les formes les
doigts les bars et bien sur la forme
perry cocktail puis dans des moules
ronds et coupé en priant s'applique aux
tons chauds prête parce que ça lève le
même que je pompe de port louis qui
dépasse les jours avec un peu de terrain
afin de favoriser l'évaporation de l'eau
il faut percer la pâte
la cuisson des sables et doit être très
lente et se faire à basse température
ok ça ça va cuire combien de temps entre
une heure et une heure dix au moins
selon la couleur qu'on veut à la fin
vous préférez les parts de les français
moi je prétends pas et moi je vais faire
très foncé les sables y sont toujours
c'est qu'un peut commander mais ceux qui
sont moins cuit moi je trouve ces crimes
ces visuels aussi c'est un peu de
graisse ou ça devienne le nombre sablé
s'est collé ça c'est ça alors voici le
résultat n'est ce pas de nos sables et
shortbread je devrais commencer par
lequel je pense les traditionnels les
traditions classiques
oui c'est ça c'est paris côté vous
pouvez voir les tentes et aux textures
et sablonneuse aérienne c'est ça le bar
mais si vous goûtez les classiques en
médaillon vous allez voir c'est une
texture différents c'est bon ça bascule
vers saint louis s'est pas seulement
qu'une bien c'est à ces cochons c'est
comme bon juste pour le plaisir je vais
goûter un doigt de dames s'agit
carrément dans la bouche c'est fou quand
même c'est la même recette même temps
que son entreprise si ça vous avez trois
choses qu'on peut pas le faire et vous
vous préférez c'est quoi j'aime les
ménages mais ce que j'aime
pour moi la fin de journée lambon un bon
ticket
p récolté un peu les copains français à
nous de découvrir si l'on préfère le
petit macaron le doigt de dames ou le
pdi cocktail
[Musique]